Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour.
Je suis venu ici pour partager
un parcours de vie,
le parcours d’un jeune homme,
18 ans,
qui habite au bout de la ligne 13,
côté Asnières Gennevilliers.
Banlieue classique, jeune homme
passionné par l’informatique.
Et comme tout jeune homme de 18 ans,
on est encombré dans cette vie, bloqué,
beaucoup de contraintes,
on ne sait pas quoi faire.
On est poussé dans nos retranchements.
Je pense que c’est la vie
de tout le monde,
de tous les jeunes hommes,
et de toutes les jeunes femmes sans doute.
Une envie, une envie de partir,
une envie de liberté,
qui me submerge complètement.
Donc je pars à 18 ans rejoindre un ami
de mes parents qui est un aventurier,
qui vit d’expéditions en kayak.
Je pars le rejoindre sur la côte ouest
du Canada, sur l’île de Vancouver,
un tout petit port, Port McNeil,
avec cette idée de retrouver
finalement la nature,
la nature fantasmée, la nature
accueillante, salvatrice,
qui va me laisser faire ce que je veux.
Je me dis :
« Tiens, je vais aller sur la plage
boire des bières.
On va être peinard, ça va
être chouette, enfin la liberté ! »
Je pars là-bas, j’arrive la nuit,
mon ami est là,
il me dit : « Monte ton kayak. »
Je le monte rapidement.
Il est 22 heures, on part en kayak.
C’est la Colombie-Britannique.
La Colombie-Britannique,
c’est 360 jours de pluie par an.
Des trombes d’eau tout le temps,
toute la nuit.
On pagaye, on pagaye, on arrive
à 2 heures du matin à un bout de forêt.
Il me dit : « J’ai ma tente là.
Tu vas mettre ta tente
à l’autre bout de la plage. »
C'est le seul endroit qui est au milieu
des arbres dans les mousses.
J’ai 18 ans.
Je lui ai dit :
« Asnières-Gennevilliers,
je ne sais rien faire. »
Il pleut.
Il dit : « Mets une bâche au-dessus de
ta tente pour ne pas être trop mouillé. »
Je fais des nœuds de lacets,
je ne sais rien faire d’autre.
Ça ne marche pas bien, ça ne tient pas.
Donc je lui demande de l’aide.
Il arrive et me dit -
Il me montre comment faire un nœud
pour attacher ma bâche.
Et moi, avec ma petite lampe, j’éclaire,
je ne vois rien, je ne comprends rien.
Je dis : « Pas grave.
Tu me remontreras demain. »
Il me saisit par le bras : « Attends,
je te montre une fois, une seule. »
Là, je me dis :
« Ouh ! C’est parti pour trois mois. »
Trois mois d’expédition pour remonter
toute la côte de la Colombie-Britannique,
remonter l’Alaska.
Je me dis : « Ça va pas être drôle. »
Et ça ne l’a pas été.
Ça n'a pas été drôle du tout.
Tout était comme ça,
j’avais le droit une allumette par jour.
Vous avez vu, il pleut énormément.
Si je n’arrivais pas à allumer
le feu avec cette allumette,
eh bien, je mangeais froid.
J’ai beaucoup mangé froid.
Mais j’ai beaucoup appris aussi.
À l’époque, je pensais
que la nature, justement,
avait cette espèce d’image très
poétique de la nature accueillante.
En fait, ce que j’ai découvert
illustre parfaitement un proverbe
« L’homme pardonne parfois,
Dieu toujours, la nature jamais. »
Je me suis construit un personnage pour
essayer de calibrer toutes mes aventures.
Je suis revenu de cette aventure trois
mois plus tard complètement transformé.
Avec au début, l’envie de ne jamais
retourner dans cet endroit,
de vivre cet enfer,
et puis quand même
une envie de partager ça.
Évidemment, quand tu as 18 ans, as 20 ans,
tu as envie de partager ça.
Tu pars à l’aventure,
c’est pour impressionner les filles.
On ne va pas se le cacher,
c’est pour son ego aussi.
Je repars, je continue
parallèlement à mes études,
mais je pars de plus en plus,
je fais de plus en plus d’expéditions.
Avec cette vision très
occidentale de l’expédition.
C’est-à-dire on maîtrise tout.
Tu calcules ta nourriture,
tu as besoin de 980 grammes de nourriture
pour faire 6 000 calories par jour.
Tu coupes les lanières de ton sac
à dos, tu coupes la brosse à dents.
J’enchaîne comme ça les expéditions.
Il y a une espèce de -
Dans l’évolution des explorateurs,
il y a des grades à faire.
On part en expédition en kayak,
on part à skis,
on fait la traversée de la calotte
glaciaire du Groenland d’ouest en est.
Après, d’est en ouest.
Et puis après, du sud au nord.
Après on fait le pôle Nord,
puis on fait le pôle Sud, etc.
On franchit toutes ces étapes.
Grande envie de partager,
donc je travaille comme guide
pour ces expéditions-là,
et toujours avec cette façon
de dominer mon espace.
Je domine cette nature,
je suis arrivé à la dominer,
je suis très fier de moi,
je me pavane dans cet univers.
Je ressens quand même quelque chose
au fond de moi qui n’est pas clair.
C’est-à-dire que je suis content,
mais il y a un truc qui ne va pas.
Je ne sais pas quoi finalement.
Je maîtrise parfaitement,
je fais des expéditions incroyables,
je reviens avec des photos,
avec des films qui sont sensationnels.
Mais, il y a quelque chose
qui me satisfait pas.
Je me souviens particulièrement
de quelque chose qui m’a troublé.
C’est une rencontre au Groenland.
Je vais faire une expédition kayak,
remonter le long d’une côte très abrupte,
il y a très peu d’abri.
Je vais devoir pagayer le premier jour
une vingtaine d’heures
pour arriver à mon premier abri.
Tout est calculé, tout est mesuré,
tout est pesé.
À l’époque,
il n’y a pas une très bonne
information météo,
on a peu d’informations sur les glaces.
Donc dernier village groenlandais,
je vais au port, je me dis :
« Je vais demander à un Groenlandais
son avis sur la météo pour demain. »
Il y a un petit vieux qui est là
en train de préparer sa ligne de flétan.
Il y a mille mètres d’hameçons
à mettre, donc il a le temps.
Je suis à côté de lui,
je commence à discuter
avec le groenlandais
que je balbutie à l’époque.
Je lui dis : « Demain, je pars en kayak.
- Ouais, super.
- Je voudrais savoir :
demain, il va faire beau ?
[Groenlandais]
Il me regarde, il me fait :
« Oui, oui, demain, il va faire beau. »
Bon, super.
Je lui dis merci, je m’en vais.
Je me dis : « C’est quand même dingue.
Il y a un vent pas possible,
le ciel est gris,
ça ne va pas changer comme ça.
Si ça se trouve, je n’ai pas compris
ce qu’il m’a dit. »
Je reviens le voir et je lui dis :
« Excuse-moi mais,
demain,
il va pleuvoir, il va faire moche ?
[Groenlandais] »
Là, il me regarde et il me dit :
« Ouais, demain, il va pleuvoir. »
« Ce n’est pas possible,
il se fout de moi.
Il est de la région, il connaît tout.
Qu’est-ce qu’il raconte là ? »
Et finalement, comme j’insiste :
« Il va pleuvoir, il va faire beau ?
Je ne comprends pas. »
Il me regarde avec un grand sourire,
plus une dent mais un grand sourire,
et il me dit : « Tu verras demain. »
J’étais vraiment troublé.
Ça n’a l’air de rien,
mais je me suis dit :
« Mais oui, il a raison.
Pourquoi tout contrôler comme ça ?
Effectivement, je verrai bien demain. »
Et j’ai vu le lendemain,
mais c’est une autre histoire.
En tout cas, cette histoire
commence un peu à me déstabiliser.
Je suis sûr de moi - ce que je disais :
on pèse tout, on est tout, on est carré.
Dans un monde où
tout le monde est comme ça.
Très très occidentale,
cette approche des expéditions,
cette approche de l’exploration.
Je suis très sûr de moi.
Je vais emmener une expédition sur la
banquise côte nord-ouest du Groenland,
plein hiver, -35°C, tout est calculé :
j’ai les cartes des glaces, la météo,
j’ai tout pesé, tout est parfait.
On ne peut pas faire
scientifiquement mieux.
On part.
Première journée : je connais l’endroit,
j’ai fait dix fois ce fjord.
Au milieu du fjord avec mon équipe,
je sonde la glace,
Et là,
il y a deux centimètres de glace.
Il n’y a plus de banquise.
Je n’ose pas bouger.
Je fais signe à tout le monde
de s’arrêter, de faire demi-tour.
Je ne bouge pas.
On a des skis, puis un traîneau
qu’on tire derrière,
traîneau qui fait 120, 130 kg.
Tout doucement,
j’essaie de sortir de ce piège.
Et là, tout s’écroule.
La glace casse, je tombe à l’eau.
Je suis déjà tombé à l’eau
mais dans des endroits
où la glace à côté était solide.
Je tombe à l’eau, mon brêlage,
le harnais qui me retient
à mon traîneau, ma pulka,
me bloque sous l’eau, je suis coincé,
l’eau est à -2°C sous la banquise.
Prenez une douche froide,
on a le réflexe de respirer comme ça.
Je tombe sous l’eau,
je suis coincé sous l’eau,
je respire, j’avale de l’eau,
je manque de me noyer.
Je n'arrive pas à remonter.
J’enlève mes gants, je détache
la pulka tant bien que mal.
Je remonte à la surface, mais
impossible de remonter sur la glace.
On a deux pics autour du cou pour
s’accrocher et remonter sur la banquise.
Il n’y a rien à faire : tout casse.
Il fait -35°C, il y a du vent.
J’entends les autres qui hurlent.
Évidemment, ils ont vu le guide
passer à travers la glace.
Ils se demandent ce qu’ils vont devenir.
Tout casse autour de moi.
Je suis obnubilé par eux.
Je dis de lancer une corde,
ils n’y arrivent pas.
Je leur dis de reculer
pour se mettre à l’abri,
ils reculent, se mettent à l’abri ;
je suis libéré.
Finalement, libéré de cette
contrainte, de cette pensée
qu’on a toujours de s’occuper des
autres avant de s’occuper de soi.
Au lieu de remonter verticalement
sur la banquise, comme ça,
ce que je vais faire, c’est que
je vais simplement enlever mes skis,
récupérer mon traîneau,
et l’enlever.
Au lieu d’arriver comme ça sur la
banquise, je vais arriver comme ça.
Je vais me récupérer, je vais
arriver sur de la glace ferme,
je vais me rouler dans la neige
pour absorber l’eau.
Un Groenlandais qui pêchait
plus loin m’a vu tomber,
il arrive en skidoo avec un traîneau.
Il me dit : « Vite, monte sur le traîneau,
je te ramène au petit village. »
Il y a un traîneau, ses deux enfants.
Je monte, je me sèche,
je suis complètement gelé,
Je n’arrive plus à bouger,
je suis transi de froid,
je suis resté très longtemps dans l’eau.
Il m’emmène.
Sur le traîneau,
j’ai les deux enfants sur les genoux.
Je vois la banquise
qui ondule sur le côté.
Juste au moment où on arrive
sur le pied de banquise,
cette espèce de trottoir de glace
qui est collé à la montagne,
la banquise casse,
le traîneau monte,
le skidoo monte,
le traîneau tape contre la glace,
elle éclate, je retombe
à l’eau avec les enfants.
Heureusement, je suis sur
un rocher, j’ai pied.
Je porte les deux enfants,
ils ne savent pas nager.
Il récupère ses enfants,
il me sort de l’eau
et me dit : « Sauve ta vie,
je sauve mes enfants. »
Il part avec eux,
traverse la montagne en skidoo
et je « cours » sur le pied de banquise
pour essayer de rejoindre le village.
« Cours » entre guillemets évidemment,
puisque tout est assez lent.
On a toujours cet esprit où on a
vraiment le diable qui nous dit :
« Arrête-toi, repose-toi,
prends ton temps »
et le petit ange qui dit :
« Non, fonce, sinon tu vas mourir. »
J’arrive à « l’hôpital »,
le médecin me regarde,
ils me font doucher,
je suis en hypothermie.
Ça dure assez longtemps.
Finalement, il vient me voir et me
dit : « Qu’est-ce que tu vas faire ? »
Entre-temps, ils avaient récupéré mes
partenaires, récupéré le matériel.
Je dis : « Je vais dormir
sous la tente tout à l’heure. »
Il me dit :
« Je pense que tu n’as pas compris,
c’est un miracle que tu sois vivant.
Considère que c’est juste un miracle.
Par contre, on va te couper
tes mains et tes pieds. »
Sur le coup évidemment,
on se dit : « Ce n’est pas vrai. »
Mais le lendemain, quand
les phlyctènes se forment,
qu’on a les doigts complètement
marrons, les ongles éclatés,
on se rend compte qu’il y a un problème.
Par chance, j’ai récupéré mes doigts,
mais tout ça,
ça a complètement fait basculer ma vie.
Il y a un superbe proverbe
qui dit qu’on a deux vies
et que la deuxième commence le jour
où on s’aperçoit qu’on n’en a qu’une.
Ma vie a commencé à ce moment-là.
À partir de ce moment-là,
j’ai décidé d’explorer les choses,
d’explorer la vie, d’une autre manière.
Parce que je reste persuadé d’une chose,
qui pour moi est vraiment
la chose la plus importante,
c’est que ce monde, on doit le repenser.
Pour repenser ce monde,
on doit changer notre façon de le voir,
changer notre façon de l’explorer,
parce que c’est le seul moyen finalement
de nous repenser nous-mêmes.
Merci.